hello and welcome to this talk from the
Yale Child Study Center program for
anxiety disorders I'm Ella Leibovitz and
in this talk we'll discuss the most
active ingredient in the treatment of
childhood and adolescent anxiety
disorders exposures and desensitization
by this we refer to the process of
gradually bringing a child into direct
contact with stimuli and the situations
that provoke their fear and that they've
previously been avoiding we'll take a
look at some keys to successfully
implementing exposures and overcoming
some of the obstacles to this treatment
the basic principle of desensitization
is easily grasped and in fact already
familiar to almost all children from a
young age every child knows that things
get easier as you do them over and over
again and that repetition dulls the
emotional impact of almost any
experience for example a frightening
movie is most scary the first time you
watch it but a child knows that if they
were to watch the same movie over and
over and over again it would turn from
an exciting experience into a rather
boring one to explain to a child how the
same principle holds for exposures in
the context of cognitive behavioral
therapy and how can be applied to
helping them overcome their anxiety
disorder we can make use of the wave
model of anxiety in this model the
vertical axis represents anxiety or
discomfort and the x axis represents
time ask a child to imagine someone with
a fear perhaps a fear of heights who
approaches a balcony and looks out over
a high edge they're likely to experience
more and more anxiety as represented
here by the rising curve of the black
line as they grow more uncomfortable
perhaps their heart racing or becoming
dizzy and their mind filling with scary
images and themselves falling they're
likely to draw back from the edge in
what we term avoidance this can lead to
a sense of relief and a rapid reduction
in anxiety although they'll feel better
at that
point as represented here by the blue
line of avoidance they won't be any
closer to overcoming their anxiety
disorder in fact next time they approach
the edge they'll feel just as scared if
not even more frightened but ask a child
to imagine what would happen if that
individual were to stay looking over the
edge and not draw back even though they
felt really uncomfortable their anxiety
which was on the rise would probably
continue to go up until it peaked at
some maximum level this is a good point
at which to remind child and parents
that although they would be extremely
uncomfortable they wouldn't be they
wouldn't be in any risk from that
anxiety nothing catastrophic would
happen they wouldn't die or faint or
lose their mind they'd just be really
uncomfortable and if they continued to
stay there for a few minutes perhaps 10
or 15 minutes their anxiety would
probably start to go down and after a
while maybe half an hour they'd find
themselves quite calm even though they
were still looking over the edge their
brain would just have had enough time to
process the information that nothing
terrible is happening of course this
would be much harder to do than the
quick avoidance and its rapid sense of
relief however by repeating that
exercise a few times they would
gradually be able to approach the edge
without their anxiety actually going up
all that much and if they practice this
enough they would soon overcome their
fear of heights this is the principle
and the way it's applied in cognitive
behavioral therapy there are any number
of ways to perform exposures in CBT but
there are some characteristics of most
successful exposure plans and together
these constitute useful guidelines for
planning and executing exposures in
treatment a successful plan will usually
ensure that exposures will be gradual
repeated and prolonged gradual exposure
is important so as to allow the child to
only expiry
a limited amount of anxiety at each step
in the process this is a little bit like
climbing a ladder where someone might
eventually climb to great height but
only ever has to raise their foot about
one foot high up in the air in order to
ensure a gradual process that well
suited to specific child's reaction the
patient and therapists work together to
create an exposure hierarchy it's
important that the first steps on the
hierarchy be quite easy and well below
the child's maximum tolerance level for
anxiety this is important both to ensure
success in this early stages of the game
in order to maintain a child's
motivation it's also important to allow
the child that there's still room to
make progress and proceed after the
initial the initial exposures have been
completed a child who undertakes a
tremendously difficult exposure right
away might withstand that experience but
could come away from it feeling like
they can't go any further forward on the
other hand the child who undertakes only
a moderately difficult exposure could
come away feeling strengthened and eager
to continue the process it's useful to
ask a child to rate how difficult each
step on the exposure hierarchy seems to
them perhaps on a scale of one to ten or
one to a hundred but it's important to
keep in mind that those ratings although
they're useful for creating the correct
sequence of exposures are only guesses
and don't accurately predict how much
fear a child will actually experience in
fact when anxious most children will
rate almost all steps or almost all
steps on the hierarchy as more difficult
than they'll actually turn out to be
this is in large part because through
the process of continued avoidance and
generalization of that avoidance the
child has come to think of many things
as difficult when in fact if they were
doing them they would see that they're
not but it's never useful to try to
convince
child that something will be easier than
they think this will only feel to them
as if we're belittling their
accomplishment rather this is a good
opportunity for a child to learn that
anxiety cheats them by making things
seem more difficult and they actually
are and for the child to experience that
they can actually undertake and
withstand challenges that seem really
difficult at first here's an example of
an exposure hierarchy taken from a child
with separation anxiety disorder as you
can see the first steps on the hierarchy
are really easy maybe just a minute in
which the parents are in another room
and then maybe a minute with the door
closed then the parents in another room
and only after quite a few steps are
taken does the child begin to undertake
exposures of a greater difficulty such
as the parents actually leaving the home
for a while in this example which is
part of the exposure hierarchy from a
child with obsessive-compulsive disorder
you can see that the steps on the
hierarchy include both exposures to
real-life situations and exposures to
the kinds of thoughts that make up such
an important facet of symptoms in
obsessive-compulsive disorder a second
important element in successful exposure
treatment is that of repetition it's
almost always a mistake to complete an
exposure just once and then to move
ahead to the next step on the hierarchy
rather each step should be performed
multiple times and this is to ensure
that the child is not only able to
withstand the anxiety of a given step on
the hierarchy but that we've actually
turned that event from an anxiety
provoking situation into a kind of
non-event that signals true
desensitization and so before moving
ahead to the next step the child should
be able to rate the previous step as
being either very easy or at least much
much easier than it was before they
started the process the third element of
successful exposure treatment is that
of duration ideally each exposure will
allow time for the child's anxiety to
rise peak and then subside before any
avoidance is undertaken this will
usually take somewhere between 15 and 20
minutes with the maximum anxiety
occurring pretty early in the process
however very often children will be
unwilling to undertake such a long
exposure at the beginning of the process
for example a child with fear of
darkness might be unwilling to spend 15
or 20 minutes even in a semi darkened
room when this is the case it's a
mistake to rigidly insist on correct
exposures of 20 minutes rather the child
should be encouraged to do a shorter
exposure sometimes even less than a
minute long in order to allow them to
overcome that to see that the anxiety
isn't as difficult as they thought it
might as they thought it would be and
then to gradually increase the amounts
of time even though these brief
exposures might be theoretically
ineffective they're actually a
tremendously important part of the
process allowing the child to allow them
to allied themselves with the therapist
and to begin undertaking exposures to
the kinds of situations that they
previously have been avoiding sometimes
the initial exposures will be so brief
or easy that they'll represent things
that the child might have been doing
spontaneously anyway in day-to-day life
and yet by defining them as an exposure
and asking the child to actively engage
in them as a way of overcoming anxiety
an important step is being taken one
special kind of exposure is exposure to
thoughts and imagination rather than to
real life situations these imaginary
exposures are useful in two different
kinds of situations one use of imaginary
exposure is as a kind of preliminary
step to real-life exposure for example a
child with social anxiety disorder who
is planning to undertake a
that such as speaking to a stranger on
the street might find that too difficult
to do right away and could benefit from
imaginary exposure in which the
therapist will guide the child through a
kind of imagined scenario of speaking to
a stranger on the street and allowing
their anxiety to rise in a moderate
fashion at that imagination and then to
subside and as the child becomes
desensitized to the idea of speaking to
a stranger they may find themselves more
willing to undertake the actual exposure
afterward another situation in which
imaginary exposures can be very helpful
are where what the child is avoiding are
actually thoughts rather than real-life
situations this is often the case in
obsessive-compulsive disorder in which
children try to avoid intrusive thoughts
that cause them distress and it can also
be the case in generalized anxiety
disorder in which childhood children try
to avoid the persistent worries that
intrude onto their mind one helpful way
of engaging in imaginary exposure is by
creating a kind of script or scenario
which could be recorded and then the
child could listen to it multiple times
over the course of the week or perhaps
by writing it in story form and having
the child read it over and over again in
one example a young man with
obsessive-compulsive disorder who had a
fear of losing the key to his home
because he imagined a burglar finding it
and breaking in and hurting his family
felt compelled to to engage in prolonged
rituals of searching for the key to his
house whenever he left a room sometimes
for up to 20 minutes at a time even
though the key might have been safely in
his pocket that young man created a kind
of personal horror story describing how
because he stopped doing the ritual he
actually did lose his key and a mean
burglar found it and broke into the home
and hurt his family and kidnapped him
and although that's a horrible story to
listen to the first time after he
listened to it for about
half an hour a day over the course of a
week or two weeks he became quite
desensitized to the thought so that he
found himself rather bored by it and his
urge to engage in the compulsive rituals
was quite dramatically reduced and so
over the course of cognitive behavioral
therapy for anxiety disorders children
will usually work through a program of
gradual repeated and prolonged exposures
bringing them into contact with the
situation's that they previously feared
and allowing them to become accustomed
to them and Toodee associate those
stimuli from the anxious response thank
you
you